let's get all our Chester honey lipstick
says the new Ford Focus RS has been on
the market for exactly a year now that
the car is finally here let's hit the
road with it
[Music]
some cars speak you feel great as soon
as you get behind the wheel boards
latest compact racer the Focus RS is one
of them the pocket rocket on 4 wheels is
popular with drivers who like the thrill
of speed and are de freitas step on the
accelerator
the first thing Ronnie notices is that
the height of the Ricardo racing seats
cannot be adjusted which wouldn't be
great for a tall driver
[Music]
but fun if Ronnie goes on to say that
driving the RS on a racetrack would be a
real pleasure but since we don't have
the opportunity to use one a country
road will do to check traction and
handling thanks for checking
[Music]
job Ronnie tips his hat to Ford saying
he didn't expect a compact sports car
like this to be so well balanced in the
curves the Chris sharp lines of the
exterior are immediately striking with a
length of four point four meters the
power packet made in Cologne is charged
with dynamic energy the engine inspires
odd packing 257 kilowatts of power and
440 Newton meters of torque with a body
weight of just 1529 kilograms if you
want to call a car like this your own
the RS has a starting price of nearly
41,000 euros in Germany dr. Ronnie says
integrated launch control can shoot the
RS from standstill to sprint quickly you
use the arrow buttons to bring up a
settings menu choose driver assist then
launch control put it in first clutch
get the gas release the clutch and
you're off
[Music]
Ronnie says so much torque is dispensed
using launch control that you're
guaranteed to get knocked back in your
seat everything about this vehicle
shouts I'm speedy really speedy the rear
spoilers really stand out as does the
dual exhaust but even so the Focus RS is
still a focus it's got four doors and a
rear hatch that opens onto plenty of
trunk space making this speedster an
ideal family car
[Music]
if the car didn't have racing seats you
might not think the RS was the fastest
focus in the series only at a second
glance to the painstaking RS details
stand out blue highlights draw the eye
to the three additional indicators for
oil temperature and manifold and oil
pressure above the main instrument panel
[Music]
precise steering working in perfect
harmony with a superior chassis means
the focus corners at high speed as if it
were on Rails and the driver can
certainly feel the power when the RS
jumps forward to a tap on the aluminum
accelerator pedal
[Music]
DeNooyer Ronnie says that personally he
really likes some of the features of the
new Ford Focus these are the coherent
interior design perfect traction and an
engine that produces loads of torque he
says that the RS is good for daily
driving of course but that's just
playing patting the vehicle would be
perfectly at home on a race track
[Music]
[Music]
you